a portable housing is hard to find in
America the problem may be most
challenging for low-income Americans
according to one study the US has only
35 affordable and available rental
properties for every 100 extremely low
income households but now an unexpected
source of low cost living space is
emerging some of America's houses of
worship are making use of a major asset
and using it to help people settle down
and start new lives what is it like to
have a place for you to hang your
pictures once again I can't even
describe what it's like to have a place
the pictures are just a small part
jeanna moment ease place over the last
two years is a one-bedroom apartment in
Arlington Virginia it's a smaller
one-bedroom than most but it's perfect
for me before coming to the V Point
apartment she lived in a shelter
she lost her house her car and two jobs
when Epilepsy made it impossible to
continue working well for six weeks had
to sleep on the floor - you could get a
bed and then it's pretty tough I mean
you have to eat when they say to eat you
have to watch what they say to watch on
TV you have to be in by 11:00 you have
to have lights out and I've never lived
a life like that before
now she has freedom and affordability
something hard to come by in the
Washington DC area here 70 of the 116
units are rented below market rate in a
county where the median household income
is a hundred and ten thousand dollars
and the average rent about two thousand
dollars a month I pay around two hundred
and two dollars a month that's
remarkable it's incredible because I
make nine hundred on Social Security so
it makes it so you can live it may be
surprising but the apartments were
funded through a partnership between
Arlington County the State Housing
Finance Agency and the church at
Clarendon it's been on this plot of land
for a hundred and ten years you see a
steeple on the front steps that lead up
into itself
a church with the name of the Church on
it and then you look and you say whoo
yeah their apartments up there
Deacon Rob Ryland says the old church
was in need of repairs but the dwindling
congregation didn't have the funds
selling the property could have brought
in tens of millions of dollars but the
church decided to try to serve the
community on a larger scale we looked up
and thought well there's all the space
up there it's not being used what can we
do housing is a traditional ministry of
the church we had to do it right
owned by a non-profit the complex
participates in federal state and local
government affordable housing programs
the church still owns the second floor
and part of the first Arlington is lost
about almost 15,000 of its market
affordable units Jill Norcross is the
executive director of that nonprofit can
you scale this I mean I think you can
there's a lot of churches but there are
a lot of faith communities in this area
a lot of faith communities that are
looking to really transform and that are
in a state of change and it can really
be a benefit to the faith community
itself as well as the the residents
they're trying to serve it's a win-win
across the country other land rich cash
for faith groups for following suit take
the Bible Way Church in Washington DC
it's created nearly 700 affordable
housing units in a zip code where home
values have increased by 207 percent
since the year 2000 it's given Deborah
Johnson and some 50 other grandparents
raising their grandchildren an
affordable place to live in a city where
it's needed most this hasn't been an
easy road the views project faced four
lawsuits including one alleging it
violated the First Amendment separation
of church and state there is federal
case law precedent now that allows a
mixed-use facility which is properly
funded and properly accounted for and
audited and so forth to you know be able
to participate in the federal
affordable housing program and that was
not clear before our project and this
congregation led the way yeah we did
that developers have built more
affordable housing over the last two
decades thanks to the low income housing
tax credit the federal program which
gives tax incentives to private
investors to build rentals for
low-income households church leaders are
looking for a new way to fulfill their
mission to take advantage and be good
stewards of the land and property they
own and a way to be relevant to their
communities Nina Jana Paul is the
president and CEO of the Arlington
Partnership for affordable housing she's
helped several churches navigate the
redevelopment process we're seeing in
communities like Arlington and
Alexandria Fairfax Northern Virginia
Montgomery County across the river
they're creating a plan a master plan to
say we want to do more of this they're
actually highlighting churches and
reaching out to them and trying to
create a path for them to achieve this
the path is clearer for Gina Momina she
may not worship inside a church but her
apartment has been a godsend what does a
partnership like this mean everything
it's a lifeline to most people I would
be at the shelter if it wasn't for the
church yes that's so right as simple as
that right simple is that in cities like
New York and LA in DC and across this
nation there are churches Catholic
churches or synagogues Wow what an
incredible opportunity here yeah what a
difference for those families who just
need the space this is the idea behind I
think some of the religious based
communities the idea of helping and
being there for the community it is
their number one mission in many case